Marcella was one of the most,
well he's the most kinesthetically overdeveloped person they ever met.
And of course over development under development tend to come hand in hand
conceptually,
um,
of overdevelopment own development
to
his physical intelligence is mind boggling.
You know,
you throw him on a standup paddleboard in three foot shop and everyone just
flies off of paddle boards when they should just stand up on them.
And he's just beautiful.
I'm just,
you just find the balance points,
but I've ever seen one soon someone learn so quickly how to handle um,
waves,
boats and fishing lines being,
you know,
free diving,
being on riding waves on paddle boards.
You know,
when you,
when you're in the marsh.
I've been a stand up fighter for many years.
I mean throwing is my core,
my core art.
When I'm doing standup training with Marcel,
I caught him with most of the throws and my repertoire one time.
I don't think I've ever caught him with a throw twice.
Wow.
And as we're world class,
while I was training with,
you know,
catch them thousands of times.
So this is a guy,
he,
he just,
you almost never see Marcello get caught more than once with something.
Um,
and it's amazing to see how he relates to the world through is kinesthetic
intelligence.
So for example,
if you're looking,
when we were looking for spaces for our school,
we'd walk into a big room and I did thinking about the dimensions,
you know,
square footage where this would be,
where that will be more so it would know if it felt good or felt bad.
If he meets you,
he's going to know whether he feels good about you or he feels bad about you and
his intuition is incredibly dead on.
But he,
he navigates the world through this Kevin Static intelligence.
And it's been a really fascinating having a school with him and diving deep with
them.
Um,
because we've been having conceptual dialogue these three and a half years or
so,
and he's really deepened conceptually.
But I've learned even more deeply in the importance of the lesson that there are
many paths to greatness and to take a guy like Marcello and to try to fit him
into a chess players.
You know,
hyper conceptual mold would be terrible because you'd be killing this shine.
And he is so great because of his just unbelievable commitment to doing it his
way.
And he's done things in extraordinary ways.
I mean,
for example,
you know how in these competitive arts,
everyone's very secretive about the repertoires.
Um,
well,
we have this program which you know well called mg inaction,
where people just two guys from around the world log in to watch all of our
souls training sessions.
His sparring sessions is lessons.
Everything.
When he was competing in Abu Dhabi submission grappling world championship,
and when jaws,
which is the Brazilian Jujitsu world championships,
we were spoiled.
We were streaming is sparring sessions every night.
So he was basically showing these competitors what he was about to say,
two weeks in,
three weeks,
four weeks.
That's,
that's it about this,
which is completely unique,
is if you're studying my game,
you're entering my game and I'll be better at.